I time for today's bar chart the Greek
banks sell-off eleven point four billion
dollars has been wiped off the value of
Greek banking stocks in the three days
of trading following the election on
Sunday which brought of course Ariza to
power now that figure matters because
the nation's banks raised more than
eleven point five billion dollars in
additional share sailed in 2014 that's
the most at least a decade to boost
their balance sheets and now that
capital has almost completely been wiped
away take a look at this chart it's the
footsie effect banks index it includes
Greece's four biggest banks alpha bank
piraeus bank national bank of greece
eurobank a gaseous it's a one year chart
and the red circle is the period you
need to look at because the red circle
highlights what's happened in the first
three trading days of the week a
forty-four percent decline the biggest
weekly decline ever it's now at its
lowest ever level the biggest for Greek
banks a trading at fractions of their
pre-crisis Peaks these are now
essentially euro sent stocks were
talking about alpha bank ninety-four
percent below its 2007 hi piraeus bank
99.2 percent below it National Bank of
Greece 99.1 percent below it and euro
bank a gaseous is ninety-nine point nine
six percent below it's 2007 peak the
Greek bank sell-off